the view these ladies are naturals when
it comes to discussing hot topics
even the ones that quickly turn into
heated arguments
i think what you said was just straight
propaganda just so we're clear i'm sorry
law is propaganda
and i'm sorry you don't shy away at all
of giving it
the way he the way you see it we are
talking about things on the show
that people aren't even supposed to talk
about and we're talking about them
in a heated way in front of three
million people every day
god bless you things may get very heated
between the ladies on air but make no
mistake about it
they are family sometimes the feelings
spill over to the next day and the next
day and the next day
but any one of us will tell you that we
are
at the core of friends there's nothing
wrong with being passionate and using
your voice
that's one of the messages in sunny's
new book i am these truths
in it she addresses the controversy
earlier this summer
when an abc executive called her low
rent which sunny believes was racial
i thought how does she tell her kids
how someone is devaluing her my son's
reaction was he was sort of
stunned my daughter was just sort of
like
don't believe that that's not who you
are they are certainly the people i've
raised them to be
you